[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver cet après midi sur public
sénat vous allez suivre une table ronde
organisée par le sénat sur
l'intelligence artificielle des
scientifiques expliquent comment les
nouveaux nouvelles technologies vont
faire évoluer nos métiers et comment la
formation doit préparer nos jeunes à ces
mutations
vous allez voir le chirurgien laurent
alexandre a tenu des propos qui ont fait
beaucoup réagir pour lui l'échec
scolaire des enfants s'explique en
grande partie par le patrimoine
génétique
je vous laisse écouter cette table ronde
mesdames messieurs l'évolution des
métiers évidemment associée à celle de
la formation initiale et monsieur
torossian je ne vous cache pas que nous
entendons souvent parler de décalage
entre les formations enseignées à
l'école et à l'université d'une part et
les compétences demandées dans les
entreprises d'autre part ce sujet n'est
pas nouveau les on a le sentiment que
l'écart se creuse dangereusement
compte tenu des enjeux en termes
d'emploi votre présence sera
particulièrement utile pour nous
éclairer sur la vision et les actions
des ministères de l'éducation nationale
et de l'enseignement supérieur
en effet vous diriger l'institut des
hautes études d'éducation de la
formation ayant pour mission principale
est dure mission d'ailleurs la formation
initiale et continue des chefs
d'établissement et des inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale à me laisse
quelques souvenirs
quelle est la stratégie des ministères
face aux enjeux abordés ce matin et
comment peut-on former suffisamment vite
les responsables la formation initiale
et les élèves pour répondre sans être
adéquat sioniste non seulement aux
demandes aujourd'hui mais également de
demain ne faut-il pas systématiser les
sages d'enseignants et de chefs
d'établissement en entreprise surtout
pour l'enseignement professionnel les
sénateurs eux mêmes réalise bien d
immersion en entreprise pour être mieux
au fait de leur fonctionnement et de
leur problématique comment juguler des
phénomènes qui explique déjà aujourd'hui
tant de
difficultés de recrutement monsieur
ombre geiq vous pourrez nous apportez
votre témoignage en tant que directeur
d'un établissement d'enseignement privé
créée par des professionnels pour les
professionnels en effet vous diriger
l'école européenne des métiers de
l'internet
fondé par xavier niel marc simoncini et
jacques-antoine granjon respectivement
fondateur de free meetic et vente
privee.com enfin la formation continue
et bien sûr un sujet essentiel
nous avons entendu de nombreux experts
nous parler de la prépondérance des
compétences transversales notamment
comportementales
en clair le savoir être comment
accompagner les actifs d'aujourd'hui
pour les maintenir dans l'emploi demain
et y faire rentrer sur tous les
demandeurs d'emploi quelles sont les
clés pour répondre à ces défis et
comment les entreprises notamment les
pme qui ont déjà du mal à opérer leur
transition numérique a intégré les
impacts futurs de l'intelligence
artificielle
je pense qu'on a des experts vous nous
tirer d'autres sujets encore pourront
est évoquée par exemple la proposition
de notre délégation à la prospective
d'intégrer dans les négociations
sociales en entreprise la question de
l'utilisation d'outils de l'intelligence
artificielle des deux robots et leur
impact surtout sur les conditions de
travail
michel tu te reposes la main voici
quelques-unes des nombreuses questions
que nous nous posons aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de cette table ronde
même si nous pourrons séquencer les
thématiques comme nous l'avons fait dans
cette introduction liminaire
nous vous proposons de prendre la parole
chacun à votre tour durant 5 à 10
minutes pour vous présenter brièvement
mais surtout pour nous dire quels sont
votre point de vue les idées les plus
importantes dont nous devons débattre ce
matin pour avancer collectivement notre
objectif est de formuler des
préconisations concrètes qui pourront
utilement répondre aux préoccupations
des chefs d'entreprise que nous
rencontrons
régulièrement sur le terrain et qui sont
aussi un titre ou à un autre
celle de tous les citoyens toutes vos
propositions sont les bienvenues pour
démontrer que nous pouvons ensemble nous
appuyer sur l'intelligence collective
humaine
nous vous remercions de votre
participation
voilà donc si vous voulez bien après
cette entrée en matière on va entrer si
je peux dire dans le vif du sujet il ya
déjà un certain nombre de questions qui
ont été posées à travers l'intervention
des rapporteurs
donc comme l'a dit michel canévet on va
vous laisser la parole 5 à 10 minutes
chacun à la fois pour présenter mais
surtout déjà commencé à répondre à ces
interrogations et ça permettra de
laisser ensuite la parole est aux
rapporteurs et à nos collègues qui sont
là pour vous interroger nous avons
jusqu'à 12h30
voilà donc je vais commencer par laisser
la parole au docteur laurent alexandre
si vous le voulez bien
docteur la haye pendant que je suis un
petit peu lent c'est le fait de vivre à
bruxelles depuis douzaine d'années et
qui m'a donc moi je suis jeune
chirurgien à l'origine et puis j'ai
travaillé sur les liens entre la
politique et l'intelligence artificielle
j'écris plusieurs bouquins là dessus je
me suis beaucoup intéressé sur au sujet
de la formation et puis j'ai créé une
dizaine de start up high tech dont une
avec docteur claude malhuret qui était
doctissimo en l'an 2000 alors juste sur
ce sujet de l'intelligence artificielle
et de la formation je voudrais je
voudrais rappeler quelques quelques
points d'abord il faut être très souple
et très flexible parce qu'on s'est
complètement trompé sur l'impact des
nouvelles technologies en matière
d'emploi et en matière économique
on a imaginé que la robotique irait
relativement serait rapide et que
l'intelligence artificielle serait lente
or c'est le contraire
la robotique est en situation de calage
la robolution n'a pas lieu pour
reprendre le terme que l'on utilisait
beaucoup il ya trois ou quatre ans en
revanche l'intelligence artificielle
pose un vrai problème pour les classes
moyennes et lé scalable un robot
n'évolue pas chaque nuit un système
d'intelligence artificielle évolué en
continu et donc il ya une adaptabilité
beaucoup plus grande de l'intelligence
artificielle par rapport à l'art par
rapport à la mécanisation robot
donc les travailleurs manuels sont
protégés pendant encore une deux ou
trois décennies
al'inverse les petites classes moyennes
centré sur les gilets jaunes et
massivement impacté par l'économie de la
connaissance et donc c'est une surprise
les travailleurs manuels sont protégés
ce n'est pas le problème aujourd'hui
le deuxième sujet qui est intéressant
c'est de voir à quel point on s'est
trompé sur l'impact sur le travail entre
1956 quand l'intelligence artificielle a
été inventé en tant que terme à
dartmouth collège
et puis 2011 les intelligences athiel
n'ont pas progressé du tout et est
n'était pas opérationnel on a été
d'échec en échec on appelle ça dans le
jargon de l'intelligence artificielle
d'hiver en hiver de l'intelligence
artificielle en 2011 alors que la
plupart des spécialistes d'heuliez a
commencé à se décourager en avait marre
d'attendre le train technologique
l'apparition de montagne de données
grâce aux données que nous mettons sur
nos téléphones portables et du
dépassement d'un certain seuil de
puissance informatique a rendu une forme
particulière d'intelligence artificielle
qu'on appelle deep learning machine
learning très efficace l'intelligence
arthuis a explosé à tel point qu'en 2015
des gens comme steve comme hawkins comme
bill gates
on craint que l'intelligence à ciel ne
devienne authentiquement intelligente
ces terres deviennent une intelligence
artificielle forte menaçante
bill gates qui était l'homme le plus
riche du monde à l'époque a dit je ne
comprends pas que les gens n'aient pas
peur
les gens avaient l'impression que l'ia
forte dotée de conscience artificielle
était au coin de la rue c'est est une
monstrueuse conneries en réalité nous
l'avons fait aucun progrès en
intelligence artificielle forte
il n'y a toujours aucune conscience
artificielle si on regarde la situation
aujourd'hui donc nous n'avons pas dit à
forte la robotique est en retard en
revanche l'intelligence artificielle
faible progresse rapidement
chose inimaginable il ya 20 ans
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
de google ou des géants de
l'intelligence ou des géants chinois
analyse un scanner mieux qu'à radiologue
mais l'intelligence artificielle est
toujours pas cap
la robotique n'est toujours pas capable
de faire un café donc on a un décalage
par rapport à ce qui avait été anticipé
ce qui doit rendre humble et nous
conduire à faire attention sur nos
prévisions à l'horizon 2060 dit ce que
je rappelle que les enfants qui rentrent
en à l'école primaire en ce moment
seront toujours sur le marché du travail
en 2070 le dernier enfin le point qui me
paraît très important c'est que nous
devons sortir des mensonges politiques
en matière d'éducation de formation
nous devons sortir des mensonges
politiques
nous souffrons en france de secourisme
comme disent les anglo saxons
nous pensons que l'école va régler tous
les problèmes nous avons une pensée
magique sur l'école or en réalité
l'école ne fait progressé que très peu
les enfants on à cacher l'échec du
dédoublement des classes de cp le
dédoublement des classes de cp da fait
progresser les enfants que de 0,07 et
0,13 écart type c'est à dire quasiment
rien malgré une dépense considérable
faire progresser les enfants est
difficile donc il n'y aura pas de
résultats magique nous avons aujourd'hui
33 % des enfants français qui quittent
l'école sans savoir lire et résumé un
texte simple de cinq lignes et cela ne
va pas beaucoup s'arranger je vous
rappelle qu'à l'échelle mondiale il n'y
a aucune expérimentation scolaire qui
est démontré une réduction significative
des inégalités intellectuelle ce qui est
un élément essentiel pour la maîtrise de
l'intelligence artificielle
la seule étude qui est montré une vraie
réduction des inégalités intellectuelle
par l'école c'est le programme lancé par
butch bouche no child left behind qui a
montré de très bons résultats
les responsables du programme sont en
pénitencier d'état pour 20 ans ils ont
tous bidouiller donc aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas de technologie pour réduire
les inégalités intellectuelle
significative et c'est un vrai problème
dans une économie de la connaissance
alors c'est pas politiquement correct et
on
il n'est peut-être pas raisonnable de
dire ça au sénat mais plots mines en
angleterre a montré que 64% des
différences de maîtrise de la lecture
sont d'origine génétique et ne sont pas
d'origine culturelle et environnementale
comme on le pensait jusqu'à maintenant
mais je vous incite à lire ce qu'a écrit
plots minque le grand spécialiste
mondial de la de la neuro génétique et
de et de l'intelligence
donc nous n'allons pas avoir de miracle
pour compenser l'échec naturel de
l'école et qui n'est pas de la faute de
l'école on a développé des concepts tous
plus foireux les uns que les autres
tous codeurs en imaginant qu'on allait
permettre à tous les enfants d'apprendre
le python alors qui est à peu près un
enfant sur quatre ou un enfant sur cinq
est capable de faire du codage
informatique donc le slogan tous codeurs
est aussi débile que tous
astrophysiciens où tous pilotes de deux
d'airbus ou tousse ou tout chirurgien
c'est totalement irréaliste et on a
d'autre part fait croire que les digital
natives les gamins qui avaient un
téléphone portable et qui allait sur
instagram à les plus compétents que les
gens qui étaient d'avant c'est
totalement faux les études montrent que
les digital natives ne maîtrise pas
mieux
les concepts ni même le numérique que
les seniors il n'y a pas de différence
aujourd'hui entre un gamin de 15 ans et
quelqu'un de mon âge en matière de
maîtrise du numérique et de maîtrise
cognitive
les digital natives ne sont pas
meilleurs que les vieux cons comme moi
donc il n'ya pas il n'y aura pas de
transformation des gamins par la magie
du code informatique et par la magie du
codage informatique nous allons devoir
nous a heurtés à une réalité qui est
l'école est une technologie aujourd'hui
qui ne marche pas bien
la formation non plus que nous
investissons peu dans la recherche en
éducation de manière à trouver des
méthodes éducatives qui permet de
réduire les inégalités intellectuelle
pour éviter d'avoir demain une fracture
sociale grandissante
sortir du déni sur ces sujets est
indispensable parce qu'il va falloir
énormément investir en recherche en
pédagogie pour faire de minuscules
progrès la concentration aujourd'hui des
cerveaux dans les métropoles est
alarmante
l'augmentation des écarts de revenus
entre ceux qui maîtrisent bien la
nouvelle économie et ceux qui ne la
maîtrisent pas est également alarmante
et je vous rappelle que chez les géants
de l'intelligence artificielle
les très bons développeurs les excellent
cadre touche l'instant jusqu'à 2
millions de dollars par mois
il y à une captation énorme des cerveaux
par les géants de l'intelligence
artificielle
donc nous allons avoir à faire face à
une situation difficile pour les
territoires quand vous regardez la carte
des compétences et la carte des revenus
les territoires sont en train de se
vider
l'intelligence artificielle n'est pas un
instrument grâce au télétravail a
distribué les cerveaux sur tout le
territoire
c'est un as c'est un instrument qui vide
les territoires de le cerveau pour le
mettre dans quelques métropoles
mondiales où les géants de
l'intelligence artificielle et les
entreprises qui sont les gagnantes de
cette économie là donne des salaires de
plus en plus important avec une
explosion des écarts
ce qui se traduit par le populisme les
gilet jaune et tous les mécanismes de
désespérance des petites classes
moyennes impacté par l'intelligence
artificielle
la grande difficulté à laquelle nous
allons avoir à faire face en matière de
formation qui est tautologique mais
décourageante
c'est que les gens intelligents
apprennent plus vite que les gens moins
doués et que donc dans une économie de
la connaissance les gens plus malins
vont pouvoir s'adapter plus rapidement
et se former plus rapidement en privé
tous les responsables de ressources
humaines vous diront à quel point il est
difficile même avec des programmes de
formation lourd de faire évoluer des
gens qui maîtrisent moins bien le
raisonnement hypothético déductive et
cela se traduit sur le marché du travail
très simplement dans un monde où on
explique qu'il va falloir changer de
métier tous les cinq à sept ans et bien
quand vous êtes moins doués et bien on
ne vous en bouge pas
parce qu'on va avoir du mal à vous
former tous les cinq à sept ans à
changer de métier en revanche les gens
plus doué se forme tout seul se
débrouillent tout seuls et leur valeur
sur le marché du travail augmente donc
si nous ne réduisons pas les inégalités
cognitive dans la nouvelle économie de
la connaissance
mécaniquement nous allons avoir une
transformation de la fonction de
production qui va se faire au détriment
des gens qui apprennent moins bien
qu'après de moins vite c'est à dire des
gens moins doués cette situation est
catastrophique
elle nécessite une vraie réflexion
politique et pédagogique et aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas pris la bonne direction
on le voit dans le supérieur j'avais
écrit une tribune dans l'express
proposant qu on offre un billet de tgv
au premier ministre pour qu'il aille à
lausanne le système français où on fait
rentrer tout le monde dans des circuits
universitaires généralistes dans des
facs poubelles et mortifère en suisse il
n'y a qu'un gamin sur trois qui rentre à
la diversité les autres vont dans des
magnifiques écoles professionnelles
tous les enfants sont bien dans leurs
baskets et on a encore vu comme à lyon
aucun gamin suisse s'immoler devant le
crous de lausanne
parce que on ne met pas les gamins suis
dans le piège horrible dans lequel on
les mêmes j'étais récemment dans une fac
où je faisais une conférence j'avais
honte
ce n'était pas une fac c'était une
poubelle donc nous n'investissons pas
sur nos écoles de sur nos universités
nous ne mettons pas les gamins là où il
pourrait être épanoui on les laisse se
piéger dans des formations et dans des
universités qui vont en faire des
chômeurs de longue durée ce qui conduit
dans un deuxième temps à la
revendication du revenu universel ce qui
est un cauchemar politique que je
combats personnellement car dire aux
gens qui n'arrivent pas à se battre
contre l'intelligence artificielle on va
vous mettre au revenu universel à 18 ans
jusqu'à attendre la date de votre mort
est horrible est insupportable mais nous
nous y dix régions si nous ne réduisons
pas les inégalités intellectuelle et si
nous ne trouvons pas le moyen de
diminuer l'exclusion d'une part
croissante de nos jeunes du marché du
travail
regardez les statistiques elles sont
absolument épouvantable il y à une
urgence politique
nous devons arrêter de nous mentir sur
l'école nous devons arrêter de
mentir sur les résultats de l'école
comme on l'a fait sur le dédoublement
des classes de cp on doit déterminer des
stratégies intelligentes abandonné la
langue de bois abandonné la pensée
magique numérique
il faut être raisonnable il faut penser
à nos enfants il faut sortir de
l'oenologie retrousser les manches
énormément travaillé réduit un tout
petit peu les inégalités intellectuelle
va nécessiter des investissements
massifs pendant des décennies et
énormément d'énergie sociales et
politiques
le temps est compté nous devons arrêter
de déconner en matière d'éducation a
l'air de l'intelligence artificielle
merci beaucoup docteur pour votre
intervention est votre part livré mais
on s'y attendait un peu pour tout vous
dire
vous nous avez posé en réalité beaucoup
de questions je fais maintenant laisser
la parole à monsieur andré gect si vous
voulez bien
bonjour dont christophe andré jacq
directeur de la nuit dans l'enseignement
supérieur ont lié à l'informatique au
numérique digital depuis une quinzaine
d'années effectivement je fais le même
constat que monsieur alexandre 1 sur les
manques on va dire pour la formation
à l'heure actuelle en france pour moi il
ya un gros souci pour l'accessibilité on
va dire par exemple alternance qui est
prenait qui mit en avant sur l'école du
numérique sur l'insertion à la
réalisation de personnes qui seront
décrochage scolaire et donc on va amener
au digital
rien n'est fait réellement que la
compagnie promettre on va dire à des
jeunes en décrochage qu'en trois mois
six mois un an maximum ils vont avoir un
métier durable dans les métiers de
l'internet du web du numérique est
encore plus de l'ia pour moi c'est une
erreur dans le sens où on le voit nous
nos étudiants qui rentre sur des
costumes de trois ans ou 5 ans ont
besoin d'expérimenter de monter en
compétences professionnelles par le
terrain avec des meilleurs retours
terrain tous nos intervenants sont des
professionnels du secteur formes sont
des retours terrain accompagne sur la
montée en compétence et c'est grâce à
ces échanges
que les jeunes arrivent à s'intégrer
dans ces nouveaux métiers
à l'heure actuelle beaucoup de jeunes
arriver sûr qu'on va dire ces métiers on
va dire en hébergeant ce que l'ia on va
dire cd buzzword à la mode
tout le monde veut aller dans ce domaine
là maintenant ça va représenter 5 à 10 %
de ceux qui travailleront dans ce
domaine les autres frères qui
travaillent autour et ça on en parle peu
quelles sont ces métiers qui sont autour
typiquement qu'on parle dia on va parler
en amont de data scientiste qui vont
préparer qui vont réfléchir à des jeux
de données
comment on va analyser mettre en place
des scénarios et des algues au qui vont
travailler pour nous on va parler aussi
de data engineer qui eux vont clean et
les dates à les nettoyer von et préparer
vont permettre que justement tout et
scénario et le moindre billet possible
parce que avec l'ia on induit quand même
beaucoup de bié lien est très
intéressante on va parler plus tôt pour
moi de machine learning dans des
systèmes qui sont très contraint là il
ya une vraie valeur ajoutée dans le sens
elle va pouvoir automatisé et travailler
à la place de l'être humain dès le
moment où on va rajouter une composante
humaine éthique morale législatives ou
autre la lia n'est plus capable à
l'heure actuelle bien entendu de faire
le travail à la place des gens
après on va dire en aval on va dire de
de toute analyse qui est fait de ses
data qui sont analysés par lien on va
avoir d'autres profils qui vont
justement interpréter les données et là
malheureusement lien le remplacera
encore pour un bon sens pas encore tout
à fait l'homme dans le sens où il ya une
partie humaine d' analyse des données ou
là il ya un accompagnement faire sur des
chefs de projets sur des métiers
excusez moi pour les anglicismes sur des
pro des métiers de producteurs par
exemple qui sont des métiers en forte
émergence liés de l'agilité alors ça
c'est on va dire là demain la nouvelle
tendance dans beaucoup d'entreprises
avec qui nous ont collaboré c'est
justement de changer on va dire les
modes de management des entreprises et
donc du coup
là où on avait historiquement un chef de
projet qui allait avoir une vision
uniquement sur son secteur
là on va faire de la collaboration
doucement de l'intelligence collective
avec typiquement une personne qui va
être en charge par exemple on va dire de
la partie facturation qui va s'occuper
aussi des moyens de paiement qui va
s'occuper aussi de la partie 1
financières technologiques et ainsi de
suite
donc on va avoir des profils qui vont
être vraiment pluri compétents ça je
pense que c'est vraiment on va dire très
important à l'heure actuelle les les
études que font les jeunes pour rentrer
sur le marché du travail est en trop du
digital ou du numérique doivent être
pluridisciplinaire
on a beaucoup on va dire deux formations
qui sont très très réductrice qui vont
permettre de mettre un pied à l'étrier à
certains jeunes
mais pour une très très limité dans le
temps et c'est l'un ou un accompagnant
je pense de la partie de l'état peut
être intéressant dans le sens où
typiquement pour pouvoir proposer des
cursus en alternance avec justement une
montée en compétences des jeunes il ya
tout un processus de reconnaissance des
titres en france pour les écoles privées
en endurance un je parle où il faut
attendre trois ans pour avoir une
reconnaissance de son titre par rapport
aux enquêtes d'employabilité des
étudiants sortis de l'eau de la
formation et c'est là où arrive le
problème comment proposer des cursus sur
des métiers émergent en respectant ses
délais légaux ça veut dire que un métier
à risque sur le marché
on va devoir attendre deux trois ans
déjà pour s'assurer de la viabilité de
ce nouveau métier et ensuite attendre
deux trois ans que des étudiants soient
rentrés dans cursus pour pouvoir lancer
les mettre en place de l'alternance ça
pour moi c'est un frein on va dire à
pouvoir couvrir ces nouveaux secteurs de
la même manière on a la particularité
d'avoir des classes à taille humaine
c'est à dire qu'il ya grand pâle de
digital ans on dit en général on ya une
perte de rapport à l'humain c'est faux
toutes nos classements d'hirson avec un
maximum de 30 étudiants
on va dire les cours on n'a quasiment
pas de cours en amphi et justement les
étudiants qui viennent chez nous qui
font le choix de venir dans les écoles
dites privées viennent chercher cette
proximité viennent chercher ces
interactions et au contraire on se rend
compte que le digital et sue source de
fracture sociale on a besoin d'avoir du
lion de l'humain les formations
e-learning sont très intéressantes en
complément de formation mais pas de
manière exclusive
si elles sont on va dire utiliser en de
manière exclusive dans ce cas là ça va
être pour une partie de la population
tout le monde ne peut pas se reconnaître
dans ce type d'enseignement et dans ce
titre de monter en compétences et celle
là où il va falloir réussir à
cartographier catégoriser entre
guillemets les attentes et les
potentiels de chacun des jeunes pour les
faire monter et leur donner un avenir
dans ce domaine eh bien merci beaucoup
pour votre vos propos je parle à l'âme
quintinie ensuite si vous voulez bien
merci merci pour cette invitation cette
opportunité de de porter le point de vue
de l' ocde donc alors que je gère une
équipe qui s'occupe depuis plusieurs
années justement des changements
changements au sein des métiers et aux
politiques qu'on peut mettre en face
pour faire face à ces changements
évidemment les nouvelles technologies
l'intelligence artificielle sont les
changements dont on parle le plus bien
que les autres grands changements
restent il ya toujours le vieillissement
de la population et qui était un très
vieux trend disons mais qui est tendance
mais qui reste quand même assez
importants sur surtout dans le
changement du contenu de métier on a
travaillé
sur ces fameux chiffres de combien
d'emplois pourraient être à risque
on est très très loin des chiffres beaux
sites et de 85% de l'emploi qui n'existe
pas encore j'y crois pas trop non plus
mais après on est très loin aussi de
ceux qui disent vos 50 % des emplois
seront détruits à cause d'eux des
nouvelles technologies alors nous on
regarde ce qu'ils sont les tâches que
les gens font dans leur dans leur emploi
et on considère qu'à peu près donc sur
les emplois individuel donc chaque
personne qui répond alain quête des cui
ce qu'ils font dans leurs emplois dont
s'est pas basée sur leur titre
professionnel et donc on estime qu'à peu
près en france on 1 16 % d'emplois qui
pourraient être à risque d'être disons
hongrie automatisé dans le sens où il ya
une composante importante de tâches qui
sont très routinière basé sur des tâches
physiques qui pourrait être donc
facilement accompli par des machines des
technologies il y en a encore à peu près
un tiers où effectivement le contenu
pourrait changer considérablement et
c'est surtout sur ce changement que je
veux mettre l'action parce que c'est pas
question durée du temps futur
catastrophique où les emplois vont
disparaître complètement mais ce qui est
sûr et on l'a déjà vu tous dans nos
emplois dans les dix ans passés par
exemple la façon dont on travaille
changent donc certaines tâches sont plus
faciles parce qu'elles sont automatisées
il ya l'ordinateur nous aident à part
faire des erreurs d'orthographe par
exemple donc ça c'est très facile on a
plus besoin presque de grammaire ou
d'orthographe y est
il ya plein d'autres exemples mais ça
veut dire qu'on a plus de temps pour
faire autre chose heureusement pour la
plupart d'entre nous ici présents des
choses plus intéressantes mais ça veut
dire qu'on doit savoir s'adapter qu'on
doit qu'on a besoin parfois de formation
vous s'adapter d'un an globalement on
sait aussi que l'emploi continue à
évoluer mais que la croix la création
d'emplois au moins un quart des emplois
créés dans les deux dernières
seni ça surtout dans des emplois qui
sont très riches un capacités cognitives
de haut niveau interactions sociales
assez complexe que je ne parle pas
seulement à vendre quelque chose un
client mais par exemple peut recevoir
des différences culturelles est donc
adapté par exemple son discours quand on
se trouve devant une personne d'une
culture différente donc les poussines
ont offert du conseil donc des encore
des interactions sociales assez complexe
et tout ça on malgré le fait que une
grande partie de la population comme l'a
dit aussi monsieur alexandre a encore
des compétences de base assez faible
sans parler des compétences de tic et
des compétences aussi de résolution de
problèmes dans des contextes digitaux
c'est là que je me permets un peu d'être
un désaccord parce qu'un effet on a vu
dans notre enquête que les personnes
plus âgées ont quand même plus de
difficultés à résoudre des pros dalle la
résolution des problèmes dans des
contextes digitaux donc on lui propose
les problèmes comme acheter des tickets
sur internet
retrouvez dans l'information mais qui
est un forme digitale que les plus
jeunes
effectivement ça peut être aussi le
résultat de l'évolution de la lède du
niveau d'éducation dans le temps donc
effectivement sa découverte assez
différents et donc dans tout ça comme
vous l'évoquez dans votre introduction
il ya effectivement des indes et
apparemment qui se crée entre l'offre et
la demande on observe déjà qu'il ya
effectivement des pénuries dans ses
compétences de haut niveau qui sont plus
difficiles à sourcer par rapport à la
demande des entreprises et par contre
dès sur +1 de compétences plus physique
que manuel
et plus facilement automatisable la
formation initiale pourrait résoudre
certains problèmes admettons qu'on
trouve la formule magique pour mieux
préparer les jeunes mais sans doute de
toute façon il y à imprégner beaucoup
d'adultes qui sont toujours là déjà là
sur le marché du travail on va pas leur
envoyer à l'école et il y avoue même les
gens qui sont à l'école aujourd'hui
comme l'a évoqué monsieur alexandre
instaurant sur la marché du travail
plusieurs années ils ont rendre besoin
de se reformer tout le temps et ce qui
se passe effectivement c'est que cette
formation est très difficile d'accès aux
gens qui en ont plus besoin donc ceux
qui sont peu compétents qui ont un
niveau de base plus bas parce qu'il ya
une barrière d'accès très loin parce
qu'ils ont leurs propres barrières la
formation les personnes plus âgées parce
qu'on les forme beaucoup moins et aussi
ce qui se trouve justement dans des
emplois plus à risque d'être automatisé
on les forme beaucoup moins de ceux qui
sont dans des emplois qui ne sont pas
autant à risque et en forme beaucoup
moins dans les petites et moyennes
entreprises par rapport aux grandes
entreprises
lorsqu'on regarde c'est effectivement
quelle solution on pourrait trouver
alors je suis d'accord que c'est très
difficile de trouver des bons exemples
mais il y en a quand même un niveau
international c'est un peu notre job de
caunes de comparer les pays et de voir
essayer des peluches et quelles sont les
expériences positives pour du côté des
individus on remarque un élément très
très important c'est quand même la
motivation à se former donc en france
par exemple
quand on demande aussi les gens auraient
voulu se former mais n'ont pas pu le
faire
seulement 15% nous disent qu'ils
auraient voulu se remet maintenant peut
pas le faire ça veut dire que le 85 %
qui restent bain soit disons il n'avait
pas envie de se former ça pourrait être
aussi qu'on lui a pas offert des
formations qui qu'ils considéraient
pouvait être utile ou sinon qu'ils ne
voient pas l'intérêt
la formation donc là c'est un grand
effort de motivation à faire donc il ya
pas mal de dison de d'alépé qui ont été
un peu plus qui ont plus de succès en
augmentant la participation dans la
formation c'est surtout de campagne de
grands informations c'est très difficile
d'établir à voile a causé fait avec des
campagnes d'information mais il ya quand
même eu beaucoup d'efforts à faire
comprendre à tout le monde de
l'importance de la formation et après il
y à d'autres barrières très concrètes
qui sont souvent plus élevés pour les
peu qualifiés
c'est le manque de temps et d'argent
les deux peuvent être un peu
interchangeables sur certains aspects
parce que si vous imaginez si j'avais
envie de prendre du temps de mon travail
ou de ma vie familiale pour me former
jeu pourra payer une nanny qui s'occupe
de mes enfants donc je vais m'informer
ça c'est pas forcément possible si on
est en salaire minimum donc il ya
effectivement des contraintes de ton
qu'on a pas qui pourrait être résolu
avec des subventions plus généreuse
attend d'eux
financiers par contre là il ya quand
même d'autres solutions par exemple
beaucoup de pays envisagent des
formations beaucoup plus courte
ça permet de après accumulé les
différents modules est arrivé en
qualifications plus tard après plusieurs
modules
ça permet aussi aux adultes qui ont eu
une mauvaise expérience à l'école de ne
pas être confronté un cours de 6 mois où
ils sont en train de travail mais se
retrouve dans un contexte de classe
lasser les formations beaucoup plus
courte est beaucoup plus avisé le
démarque le suisse la suisse le font
depuis très longtemps avec pas mal de
succès et après bon après il ya toutes
les initiatives liées aux coûts donc à
france il ya le compte personnel de
formation va voir ce comment ça va
effectivement ce marché mais il ya
beaucoup de pays qui regarde cette
expérience qui sont en train de
l'introduire en europe et les pays bas
la flandre par exemple en belgique
du côté des entreprises c'est un peu les
mêmes histoires donc en premier ce qu'on
observe ce qu'on trouve retrouve dans
les réponses des entreprises au sein une
préférence pour leur recrutement très
tristement donc la première raison pour
laquelle les entreprises ne font pas ce
qu'ils préfèrent trouver des plus jeunes
ou de mieux former sur le marché du
travail est viré ce qui ne peut pas
accomplir plus accomplir leurs tâches à
cause du changement mais après il ya
toujours donc là aussi il faut faire
quand même des campagnes d'information
après il ya toujours le manque de temps
donc la pression sur dans le comtat ce
travail très importante pour les pmi
parce que si vous imaginez que 7,3 dans
l'entreprise est une personne va se
former c'est un tiers de votre force de
travail qui disparaît et après il y a le
coup encore le coût de la formation je
pense que pour les entreprises encore il
ya deux très bons exemples il y a
il ya déjà des programmes pour inciter
vous l'avais dit je pense un peu dans
l'introduction le management la
leadership pour les sensibiliser à
l'importance de la formation en
entreprise de créer des environnements
qui sont qui sont disons porteurs de de
l'apprentissage c'est à dire la
formation n'a pas besoin d'être une
formation dans un cours particulier on
sait que la vaste majorité on à sortir
un papier l'année dernière la vaste
majorité de l'apprentissage se fait sur
le poste par les collègues tout seul et
c'est déjà créé cet environnement c'est
très important
il y a aussi des programmes qui font
ainsi que les petites entreprises ce
groupe ensemble pour pouvoir trouver des
par exemple des prestataires pour la
formation c'est très difficile pour une
petite entreprise dans une petite zone
peut-être rural disons de trouver
quelqu'un qui puisse faire le court donc
à se mettant ensemble ce problème un peu
réduit ça s'appelle des groupes training
organizations existe dans plusieurs pays
et encore un exemple intéressant c'est
un exemple en corée ou là les grandes
entreprises sont liées aux petites
entreprises souvent dans leurs filières
de production pour encore aider les
petites entreprises dans surtout les
tous les défis de formation et je finis
par des programmes encore pour les
petites entreprises est très difficile
d'identifier les besoins de formation
donc comme on y vont regarder la force
de travail et dire balle toi je pense
que si tu te former un ça on pourrait
améliorer je suis pas la productivité on
pourrait adopter de nouvelles
technologies etc
donc il ya des programmes par exemple en
finlande une qui aide les petites
entreprises à faire ça à faire un bilan
de leur besoin et après organiser la
formation dont on a besoin et parfois
aussi aux démarques en finlande en
donnant des des chômeurs pour remplacer
la personne qui part informations non
conforme de chômeurs
avance on le met dans l'entreprise pour
remplacer la personne qui s'en va nous
c'est un peu gagnant pour tout le monde
parce que la personne peut se former le
chômeur va se former et l'entreprise au
moins en partie natta à voir disparaître
leur les le réchauffement
je trouve qu'il ya quand même des bons
exemples qui peuvent être voilà qui
pointe peuvent être prises est considéré
par la france qui est qui qui au marché
relativement bien dans d'autres pays
merci beaucoup madame de nous avoir
parlé de façon concrète des travaux de
l' ocde la parole maintenant si vous
voulez bien monsieur torossian même la
présidente merci de nous recevoir ce
matin pour parler d'un sujet très vaste
évidemment tour de la formation
j'ai bien écouté le docteur alexandre
peut-être quand on pourra ensuite
discuté on a beaucoup attaqué l'école
donc je vais devoir la défendre et et
d'une certaine manière peut-être vous
regardez ce qu'on a fait déjà et je vais
tout de suite commencer par lycée
professionnel quand vous regardez
l'évolution du lycée professionnel sur
les trente dernières années malgré tout
malgré tout il ya quand même une très
forte évolution
si vous rentrez dans les ateliers
aujourd'hui il ya plus de graisses là
plus rien caissier à la place il ya que
des machines à commande automatisés les
élèves sont il ya plus de bruit dans nos
ateliers et ce sont des espaces qui
donne envie c'est on est je suis
d'accord qu'il a encore peut-être du
chemin à parcourir mais ne négligeons
pas aussi le chemin parcouru et regarder
l'investissement de nos régions sur le
bâti scolaire notamment lycée
professionnel ces trente dernières
années il est remarquable et
on peut jeter la pierre mais temps en
temps c'est quand même bien de regarder
lisez la vérité j'étais avec le député
villani à mayotte au moins 2 au mois de
novembre pour la promotion du plan
villani torossian justement pour les
mathématiques et nous avons visité un
lycée le lycée professionnel du bois et
bien le lycée partielle du bois à
mayotte
c'est formidable voilà et y compris dans
nos lycées agricoles les choses ont
quand même bien changé donc ça c'est la
première chose que je voulais dire c'est
que le lycée professionnel a su intégrer
les nouvelles technologies qui ont été
autour de l'automatisme et de la
l'automatisation des processus
donc ça ça veut dire qu'on a été capable
de s'adapter teaser à la révolution
technologique qui n'est pas de l'ordre
de dia mais qui est de l'ordre du
numérique
ça c'est une réalité
tous les élèves du lycée professionnel
aujourd'hui maîtrise les outils
numériques puisque toutes les commandes
sont numériques je veux dire y compris
pour changer sur un tour je dire c'est
numérique je veux dire c'est fini le
temps où il fallait manipuler des des
fraises et donc c'est tout automatisé
alors que dire je dire j'ai retenu je
retiens plusieurs choses d'abord sur la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
et l'impact sur les métiers à
l'éducation nationale l'enseignement
supérieur de type de métier et métiers
le métier élèves
on va en parler dans un seconde le
métier professeur un million d'emplois
malgré tout ça ne touche et les métiers
de l'encadrement alors surtout ces trois
secteurs je dirais que l'intelligence
officielle n'est pas une menace
aujourd'hui sur ses trois métiers élèves
professeurs et encadrement puisqu'on est
au coeur de l'humain il est peu gros il
est peu probable que
les humains accepte d'être disons en
contact à lui on sait que les humains
aujourd'hui après une beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup mieux quand ils sont en
contact d'humains donc ça c'est une
chose dont il n'y a pas de menace
structurelle et systémique des emplois
de professeurs professeur reste encore
un métier d'avenir
donc ça c'est la première chose par
contre l'intelligence artificielle vient
intégrer les trois métiers que j'ai
cités élèves professeurs et cadres comme
fonctions support et là on a plutôt une
synergie gagnant gagnant à construire on
est au démarrage prenons le cas des
professeurs la question qui se pose est
inria il travaille
inria travail d'art je mens c'est la
question du professeur augmenté il
s'agit pas du salaire malheureusement
mais bien évidemment de tout ce qu'il
intelligence officielle va permettre de
dison d'aider le professeur dans son
travail au quotidien
alors ça peut être vu comme une menace
d'un point de vue des compétences
professionnelles est ce que mes
compétences professionnelles sont
remises en cause parce qu'il ya une
machine qui analysent mieux les erreurs
des élèves ou que moi par exemple comme
nous nous disons aujourd'hui et c'est ce
que la direction du numérique éducatif a
lancé des partenariats avec des start up
d'intelligence artificielle sur les les
assistants les assistant professeur donc
su pour eux ici on est sur le cycle 2
c'est à dire le tout début de la
scolarité cycle de cycle 3 et donc on a
lancé aujourd'hui des processus
recherche développement pour permettre à
tous nos professeurs d'être outillés à
terme disons outils qu'ils utilisent
intelligence artificielle pour mieux
analyser les difficultés scolaires des
élèves et être finalement plus efficace
dans le renseignement
pourquoi tout simplement tout simplement
parce que quand vous avez des classes de
30 40 élèves c'est difficile disons
d'être captif sur chacun d'entre eux le
travail est colossal
et si des machines peut aider des
professeurs à mieux analyser ce qui se
passe sur l'apprentissage du calcul
l'apprentissage de la lecture des
langues étaient très bien nous en sommes
nous sommes nous sommes intéressés donc
c'est pas tu ne ce n'est pas une menace
c'est plutôt quelque chose qui est qui
est intéressant pour nous alors deuxième
point deuxième point prenons le cas du
métier élèves
eh bien c'est la même chose le métier
élèves rendre plus efficace et
apprentissage c'est aussi peut-être
quelque chose qui peut être une réponse
aux craintes du docteur alexandre et
j'allais dire que déterminée qu'est ce
qui dans les apprentissages restera
quand on aura tout oublié
il s'agit pas d'une certaine manière de
mettre en opposition les connaissances
puisque les connaissances ont tendance à
être a évolué mais qu'est ce qui reste
quand on a tout oublié on sait que la
plasticité du cerveau
elle est maximale quand on est jeune
c'est dire tout le monde c'est au tour
de table qu'il est difficile d'apprendre
le chinois
quand on a plus qu'on a dépassé les 50
ans ça peut arriver mais c'est plus
difficile que quand on a deux ans ça on
le sait donc la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'il faut dans l'enseignement pour
garder cette plasticité intéressante qui
permet d apprentissage
alors la réponse est dans le livre de
stanislas dehaene à professeur au
collège de france qui décrit finalement
les quatre piliers de l'apprentissage
je le rappelle je le veux je vais d
rappeler ici d'abord être en capacité
d'attention c'est vrai j'allais dire du
bébé jusqu'à l'adulte d'être en capacité
d'attention
donc il faut pouvoir se concentrer et se
concentrait peut-être plus que 3
secondes
je le dis j'ouvre une parenthèse la
capacité de concentration de nos élèves
a diminué je le dire avec l'âge non
quelques peluches quelque chose être en
capacité de concentration
ensuite est en capacité d'engagement
c'est le deuxième pilier il faut être
engagée enfin il faut avoir envie
si vous n'avez pas envie eh bien vous
allez pas arrivé s'il donnait pas envie
aux travailleurs aux adultes de se
former ça va pas marcher donc la
deuxième le deuxième pilier c'est
l'engagement
le troisième pilier c'est l'essai erreur
le cerveau fonctionne par ailleurs on a
le droit de se tromper et moi je dis
aujourd'hui aux cadres y compris aux
inspecteurs que nous formons vous avez
le droit à l'erreur
prenez des risques prenez des risques et
c'était cet essai erreur un enfant qui
apprend à marcher bas ils tombent
quelqu'un qui apprend aussi si vous
pensez pouvoir faire du vélo du premier
coup ça va pas marcher
si vous prenez aucun risque au ski vous
serez jamais un skieur donc quelque part
laissé erreur c'est ce qui permet au
cerveau de stabiliser ses
d'apprentissage et d'être accompagnées
sur les deux de ses deux premiers
piliers et le quatrième pilier c'est la
consolidation pour pas que les choses
partent en fumée est en quelque sorte si
on réfléchit un petit peu sur le mode
horde que je donne aujourd'hui à
l'institut que je dirige
c'est que les quatre piliers
d'apprentissage du bébé s'applique aussi
pour les adultes
en termes de formation continue donc si
on appliquait la méthode la méthode de
stanislas dehaene dans regardant comment
le fonctionnement le cerveau humain
fonctionne
eh bien on n'a que des pistes
intéressantes qu'on peut décliner en
fonction des publics
donc ça c'est ce que je voulais dire
dans un premier temps dans un deuxième
temps je surveille mon temps de parole
la question de notre capacité à former
les adultes et les élèves qui nous sont
confiées dans notre organisation
alors les élèves vous les connaissez
mais les adultes les professeurs est ce
que nous avons été brillants ces
dernières années dans notre capacité à
former accompagner nos professeurs qui
est aussi comme tous les travailleurs de
ce pays ont besoin de formation continue
alors la réponse est un petit peu oui et
non d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui les institutions notamment
les questions nationales met en oeuvre
un plan stratégique de formation et
qu'est ce qu'on va retenir de ce plan
stratégique la dgrh le plan stratégique
de formation continue à trois ans voire
cinq
qu'est-ce qui est qu'elles sont c'est
quels sont les éléments qu'on peut
retenir en terme disons de philosophie
alors c'est assez simple finalement
il ya tout se passe et ça rejoint ce que
ce que disait notre dame cantini c'est
que les choses se passent localement la
circonscription
c'est à dire le district pour les
premiers le premier degré la
circonscription apprenantes
l'établissement apprenant faire
redescendre dans l'établissement les
structures d'apprentissage et de la
formation continue
voilà une direction dans laquelle nous
devons nous engager
au lieu de faire sortir nos professeurs
des établissements scolaires en leur
disant que vous allez vous former à
poitiers pour et une trêve et lever très
belle ville ce qui est important c'est
surtout de pouvoir apprendre d'avoir un
processus de formation continue à
l'intérieur même de son établissement
c'est ce que font remarquer blement les
établissements asiatiques
est-ce que vers quoi nous devons tendre
donc ça c'est la première était la
deuxième idée
c'est finalement un mix qu'on appelle
une hybridation entre des présentiel
c'est à dire parce que ce que mes deux
collègues ici à côté décrivez c'est à
dire des petites classes à taille
humaine une trentaine de personnes d'une
part et d'autre part un distanti elle
est là aussi l'intelligence artificielle
et toutes les nouvelles technologies
nous ouvre des voies tout à fait
intéressante pour booster la question de
distance yale qui vous savez et est
quand même un peu un échec les mook dont
on parlait tant il ya quelques années
ont disparu du paysage
seuls 5 % des étudiants sont des adultes
sont capables de suivre un mook je veux
dire jusqu'à son terme
donc il ya une sorte de désengagement ça
on le sait est donc tout l'enjeu ici
c'est de faire ce que le distant ciel de
chez soi le soir par petites capsules
les petits pas les open badge l'aller
les
accumuler des crédits qui permettront
ensuite d'obtenir une certification donc
là aussi toutes ces parcours
l'intelligence artificielle va nous
permettre d'augmenter notre efficacité
sur le distance yale qui est pas facile
quand vous êtes au quotidien que ce soit
dans une entreprise que ce soit dans une
école et que vous demandez bien le soir
après avoir travaillé pendant six heures
face à des élèves bien vous allez rester
une heure à travailler avec enfin 2 face
à un ordinateur qui va vous faire
travailler je sais pas trop quoi
mettons le python et bien c'est
difficile donc
donc oui oui on a des efforts et je suis
très confiant de ce côté là sa capacité
à rendre attractif
les formations distant ciel qui
permettront de résoudre la question un
petit peu donné territoriales le dernier
point sur lequel je voulais je voulais
aborder
c'est la question effectivement plateau
ce sera c'est la question effectivement
dû de la formation des élèves au niveau
de l'informatique
alors ça c'est un sujet que cédric
villani a traité dans son ouvrage et
qu'on a traitées dans notre rapport sur
les mathématiques c'est un véritable
enjeu aujourd'hui diront qu'il ya pas de
dialectique très posé très ferme sur la
question faut-il que 100% des élèves
français mettant de 14 ans h codé en
python docteur alexandre nous dit
probabilité que 100% des élèves est
assez faible et donc la question qu'on
peut poser aujourd'hui c'est à quel
niveau on peut avoir des apprentissages
il faut savoir comment ça fonctionne
donc nous allons lancer très
prochainement une étude qu'ils ont
vraiment systémique sur qu'est ce que
doit être la folle l'éducation à
l'informatique et pas uniquement au
numérique mais vraiment l'informatique
de l'école primaire jusqu'à les licences
je vous rappelle ici que tous nos élèves
de cm1 et cm2 tous nos élèves sont sont
en contact du logiciel scratch et donc
qui était un premier logiciel inventé
par le mi6 et un premier du sed
programmation donc tous les élèves de
france font de la programmation tous
donc nous avons introduit de manière
assez avec un certain succès au collège
la colle de continuum sur ce crash
donc on va pas dire aujourd'hui
si que nos élèves ne sont pas formés à
l'algorithmique à la programmation donc
on peut affirmer même que c'est plutôt
un succès la question c'est est ce qu'on
passe de scratch qui est assez ludique
qu'un premier contact avec
l'algorithmique la pensée informatique
d'une certaine manière est ce qu on
passe à l'étape suivante c'est à dire on
monte en gamme 4e 3e par exemple c'est
une vraie question qui peut se poser est
ce qu'il faut que tous nos élèves de 4e
et 3e dans un collège unique et
obligatoire soit formé à l'apprentissage
du piton par exemple ou d'un langage de
programmation ou de la logique de la
logique informatique manière cette
question est encore ouverte
alors après évidemment on va vous sur la
spécialisation je veux dire on a ouvert
hennessy numérique et sciences
informatiques dans le lycée ou dans la
réforme du lycée on a 15 % des lycées
des lycéens du lycée général des garçons
qui ont choisi informatique 2,7 pour son
défi donc je signale à la commission ici
qu'on a au delà de la question des
territoires des problèmes de dison liées
au genre et donc c'est une question
qu'il faut pas éluder
donc la question est ouverte je pense
que les us national n'a pas encore
répondu
peut-être que c'est une question
politique un choix de société
il reviendra à la commission de
d'indiquer à nos ministères l'a
peut-être la voie à suivre
si on retiendra votre proposition
d'interpellations merci beaucoup
alors nous allons poursuivre et terminer
avec madame s et peut-être monsieur
dissous je ne sais pas si vous allez
parler à deux voix enfin bonjour merci
de votre invitation
peut-être vais-je commencé puisque en
fait l'étude fait est un axe du projet
que nous avons lancée et monsieur
d'histoire interviendra plus peut-être
sur la partie chiffrée et qu'on s'a
l'étude qui a été élevé donc je suis là
devant ouais je travaille au medef lille
métropole
dans ce cadre là j'ai deux casquettes
une casquette plus nationale aux cô avec
laquelle j'accompagne des branches
professionnelles sur les prospectives
emplois métiers en lien avec les
partenaires sociaux et des ministères
notamment la
afp miss à l'éducation nationale et et
les opérateurs hôtes hip hop cas
maintenant qu pardon et je travaille
également en région et sur des projets
qui qui aura semble écosystèmes mais
également sur des problématiques
d'emploi de formation de recrutement et
de prospective sur les emplois et les
métiers
donc je vous propose de vous faire
l'état des lieux en fait du projet qu'on
a lancé un an de france qui se veut être
une réponse et surtout apporter des
solutions concrètes opérationnelles aux
chefs d'entreprise et à leurs
collaborateurs sur une question ou sur
un démo l'intelligence artificielle qui
sont fort usitée dont on entend beaucoup
beaucoup parlé depuis 18 mois ou 4 enfin
bon peu importe mais qui reste très
mystérieux pour le chef d'entreprise de
même pour nous-mêmes je pense voilà donc
l'idée de cette démarche en othe france
était de se dire et je me suis rapproché
de la dgefp pour leur proposer cette
initiative c'est comment construire en
fait sur un territoire
le terreau favorable à l'émergence de
l'ia de manière concertée avec
l'ensemble des acteurs chacun apportant
sa pierre et son expertise et l'idée
c'est de faire un mouvement d'ensemble
une dynamique régionale pour d'ailleurs
dupliquer pourquoi pas cette expérience
se créer des outils en tout cas créer
des synergies en capacité d'aider nos
entreprises donc l'état que je remercie
d'ailleurs un a déjà fait à a accepté de
suivre ce projet donc un projet de 2 en
2019 2020 autour de quatre axes que je
vais vous présenter au départ on avait
un constat pourquoi lier alors moi
j'avais accompagné des démarches autour
de la transition digitales numériques
des branches etc
l'ia semble être l'étape à venir nous
semble l'étape à venir mais je parle
vraiment toute humilité on commence en
entendent parler en entreprise
on en entend bien sûr parlé à droite à
gauche par les auteurs des conférences
et cetera on
voix des rapports sortir le rapport de
série villani france stratégie bon et en
même temps on a cette volonté et on le
sent bien au niveau des branches et des
interpro on sent la volonté aussi du
gouvernement de nous accompagner sur
cette thématique
tout ça a fait émerger ce projet alors
l'idée encore une fois et ça sera
peut-être plus là dessus que je vais
insister c'est le pragmatisme en fait
dont il faut faire preuve autour de
cette notion est autour de
l'accompagnement nos entreprises est
avant tout l'idée de ce projet c'était
de désacraliser ou en tout cas de
sensibiliser de communiquer autour de ce
sujet très clairement quand vous en
parler un chef d'entreprise il est bon
il fait lié en entend parler il va
falloir que j'y aille d'une manière ou
d'une autre mais c'est quoi
comment je fais et on a eu des réactions
d'ailleurs très intéressante quand on a
fait des manifestations vous présenter
le projet je possède un ou deux chefs
d'entreprises allemands ils disent mais
montrait bien ok on est partant mais
j'appelle qui est moi j'ai trouvé cette
question très pertinente valu toute
simple la part d'un chef d'entreprise
mais c'est comment je fais j'appelle qui
et comment je prends ce sujet
loin de 10 possible parfois très
complexes et c'est donc la manière dont
on a bâti ce projet c'était déjà de
réunir l'écosystème aujourd'hui on a les
entreprises on a les organismes de
formation on a les labos là les
chercheurs on allait les organismes
privés publics et caetera et on sent que
finalement chacun une part
d'informations sur ce qui existe autour
de l'ia mais que globalement cette
information n'était pas du tout partagé
pour nous il est essentiel de commencer
par une étude alors ne pas tomber dans
le travers de l'étude on sait on fait
une étude en les comptant voilà on a
fait des livres etc
l'idée c'était de partager un constat et
de commencer à établir une cartographie
du territoire sur ce kit elia
alors cette cartographie autour bien sûr
des entreprises par secteur d'activité
savoir quelle entreprise les ressentis
d'ailleurs d'entreprises autour de cette
question leur degré de maturité leur
degré de connaissance de ce que
pouvaient être liés à de la manière d'un
tel pouvait impacter leur organisation
une cartographie autour des organismes
de formation aux voir finalement parce
que les gens les salades les entreprises
ne vont pas faire former leurs salariés
à marseille quand on habite lille donc
qu'elle organise deux formations étaient
aujourd'hui en capacité ou écoles de
travailler sur l'ia est en mesure
d'apporter de l'aide à nos entreprises
qu'elles étaient aussi les niveaux
touchés puisque effectivement moi j'ai
pas trop de craintes pour les niveaux
supérieurs
je travaille sur des proches plutôt
industrielle type e recyclage on a là
beaucoup d'opérateurs de tri beaucoup de
maintenance beaucoup de chauffeurs une
population peu qualifiés au départ j'ai
plus d'insectes d'inquiétude pour ces
personnes-là et la manière dont on peut
les accompagner
donc cette cartographie n'a été fait en
parlera et puis une cartographie aussi
des entreprises qui accompagne déjà
qu'ils offrent déjà des solutions il ya
à des entreprises que ça soit partie
logistique santé etc
voilà donc cette étude a été lancée
début janvier elle a été restituée le 17
septembre vous la retrouvez vous l'avez
peut-être vu on a créé un site qui a
acheté f.org
on en a fait délivrer mais également
l'intégralité de l'étude est disponible
vous pourrez aller la consulter
le deuxième projet je laisserai du coup
hervé parler de l'étude le deuxième
projet c'était de travailler sur de la
certification sur la formation sur
l'accompagnement déjà voir quels étaient
les points manquants en othe france
éventuellement sur la pala le trail de
l'ia et puis on s'était dit on peut
peut-être créer une certification mais
laquelle parce que finalement tous les
niveaux sont concernés on a les bons et
chemin faisant et à l'écouté des
entreprises
et encore une fois on retombe dans la
nécessité du pragmatisme et de
l'opérationnalité de la rapidité pour
l'entreprise on s'est dit tiens on va
travailler sur ce qu'on a appelé un chef
de projet il ya c'est à dire comment
former un homme clé qui pourra aller
dans l'entreprise et faire la passerelle
entre les métiers entre la direction
entre l'écosystème aussi régionale
puisque une fois qu'on est en entreprise
il faut aussi dirigé l'entreprise vers
les bons acteurs et les bonnes personnes
ou les bons organismes de formation donc
ça c'est une certification qu'on est en
train de créer qui sera opérationnel en
septembre 2000 ventes et dont on espère
qu'elle portera ses fruits sur
l'accompagnement concret de l'entreprise
ensuite l'accompagnement des entreprises
c'est aussi les sensibiliser et on se
rend compte en fait en transe que dès
qu'on fait une manifestation autour de
l'ia les gens viennent ils viennent
parce qu'ils ne savent pas mais ils
savent qu'ils doivent venir
en fait c'est un peu et on aide nous
même été étonné du nombre de personnes
présentes à chaque fois qu'on a lancé
une manifestation autour de l'ia sur des
sujets divers et variés et on pense que
la sensibilisation avant tout des
directions des comex neko dire ou de la
tpe est indispensable pour lancer un
mouvement d'ensemble puisque aujourd'hui
on peut se focaliser sur la formation
mais l'entreprise doit être attractive
et doit pouvoir présenter ou se projeter
dans un projet et vous avant tout que la
direction soit soient convaincus et
surtout comprenne ce qu'il ya derrière
la thématique ya et en quoi elle peut
lui a amené la compétitivité en tout cas
des des atouts vis-à-vis de ses
concurrents
alors on travaille sur cet
accompagnement à la fois à travers de la
sensibilisation et puis d accompagnement
plus long de 7 jours qu'on a mis au
point donc à geof ans a été d d d d
accompagnement personnalisé qu'on met en
oeuvre et on se rend compte en fait que
ça soit la tpe mais aussi des grosses
entreprises nous n'avons dans tous les
territoires une entreprise phare sur nos
territoires
elles sont peu avancé sur le sujet l'ia
et elles ont besoin même à leur propre
niveau alors qu'elles ont quand même des
des armées entre guillemets de gens
compétents de gens formés elles ont
besoin de 2,2 d'être avec d'autres
entreprises elles ont besoin de
connaître leurs écosystèmes elles ont
besoin aussi de retour d'expérience et
on travaille beaucoup sur ce sur ces cas
d'usagé retour d'expérience pour dire
regardez par exemple telle entreprise en
plus comme on prend des entreprises de
la région
elle s'identifie très vite tout le monde
se connaît dans une région
et quand c'est mon voisin ou celui où
d'écran de grosses entreprises que je ne
citerai pas mais qu'ils sont présentes
sur le territoire qui viennent expliquer
comment elles ont pu faire est-ce que ça
a pu leur apporter tout de suite à mon
égard comme en fait c'est vraiment on
essaye beaucoup de travailler sur cette
sensibilisation sur cet accompagnement
est aussi parce que le recrutement est
difficile et on verra comment vous déjà
on a identifié beaucoup de manque de
formation beaucoup de manques et on va
avoir des preuves de recrutement on se
dit aussi pour avoir rencontré des
chercheurs que pour attirer ces talents
là il faut que l'entreprise soit
attrayante attractive et au delà du
salaire qui est bien sûr une très
important c'est le sens qui est donnée à
la démarche de l'entreprise autour de ce
projet il ya donc on travaille aussi
beaucoup beaucoup sur ces questions et
puis on a fait quelques
on a également travaillé commissaire
d'éducation nationale parce
qu'effectivement se dit aujourd'hui que
dans les lycées notamment où les
collèges les enfants d'aujourd'hui
seront les salariés de demain c'est le
c'est une vérité implacable et
finalement on les sent aussi très peu
investi dans la question de l'ia et on a
travaillé sur un petit film concourt je
filme le métier qui me plaît en leur
demandant de travailler sur la
thématique de l'ia dans les collèges
dans les lycées en france alors on a eu
plein de films hyper drôle en fait mais
qui nous montre aussi finalement le gap
entre ce qu'ils peuvent comprendre nous
imaginer de skelia et leur quotidien en
fait donc ça aussi on a voulu la
travailler aussi avec avec la partie
éducation nationale donc aujourd'hui on
est en plein dans cette dynamique on est
sur la deuxième année le succès était
tel qu'on l'a créé effectivement euros
de france que 1 heure dans la cité l'ia
dans lequel effectivement on se souhaite
réunir toute cette énergie et travaille
à plus long terme est encore une fois
donc aujourd'hui la région est investie
l'état la direccte et on n'en ont créé
une communauté de personnes autour de
lia avec notamment un annuaire aussi
qu'on souhaite créer sur
l'identification des personnes clés ou
des organismes clés qui pourront aider
les entreprises à se repérer dans cette
espèce de deux choses très abstraite en
fait un lieu assez sais quoi je commence
par quoi j'appelle qui me voilà donc on
travaille beaucoup sur ces questions là
et là on travaille beaucoup avec les
branches puisqu'en fait sur le
territoire il ya des branches qui
peuvent aussi relayer tous ces messages
et on les associe beaucoup à nos notre
exercice de sensibilisation et de
communication et aujourd'hui voilà on
sait que la formation c'est une
difficulté madame l'adie pour une
entreprise c'est le conte la formation
la réforme qui est entrée en vigueur
voilà ne facilite pas la lisibilité et
aussi les financements parfois de
déformation et puis aussi le temps qui
une problématique est encore une fois
des formations qui doivent être
pragmatique on se rend compte que plus
tôt quand on est sur des certifications
métier ou quand on est sur des
dispositifs adaptés personnalisés ça
marche plutôt bien
voilà je m'arrête parce que merci
beaucoup je vais compléter par rapport à
l'étude bonjour et merci de cette
invitation
je travaille dans un cabinet qui
accompagne les entreprises et
fédérations l'heure des mutations
économiques et technologiques et j'ai
commis à peu près 50 rapport sur des
questions d'évolution l'industrie du
futur etc etc
dans notre dans notre cas cette étude
donc a été effectué avec les cabinets
catalyseur dean sur la gestion dont des
compétences et comment elles évoluent à
dix ans ce qui est intéressant tout
d'abord de voir c'est que le cas du
territoire c'est déjà un territoire
dynamique ce qui vient d'être dit on à
400 chercheurs 117 start up etc
donc on ne part pas de rien et ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir la
dynamique entre 2017 et 2027
et pour cela on a étudié 23 secteurs de
l'économie des hauts de france
ça va de la banque en passant par la
restauration les transports etc
est ce qu'on peut remarquer ces deux
catégories de métiers il ya des métiers
qui sont impactant qui font évoluer
l'économie du territoire et puis à des
mythiques sont impactées et très souvent
lorsqu'on fait des études sur
l'intelligence artificielle on pense à
ceux qui sont impactant à longueur de
temps de par des dates analystes data
scientiste etc mais ce n'est qu'une
petite partie de la totalité des métiers
qui sont sains qui vont devoir
travailler avec l'intelligence
artificielle le premier point donc
cesser de ces emplois qui sont impactant
ce sont des
pour la plupart des des métiers qui sont
avec de la technologie
ils sont là pour développer de nouvelles
applications d'intelligence artificielle
de travailler sur la data de permettre
l'indemnisation de ces de ces
développements à l'intérieur des
entreprises du territoire
ça c'est une première partie si on
regarde aujourd'hui la typologie des
emplois sont des minimum bac + 4
vraiment qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'expérience bac +5 doctorants donc déjà
première points on est sur une toute
petite partie de la population
voilà ça c'est ce le point important est
le deuxième point c'est comment les
formes
aujourd'hui on les forme avec nos
grandes écoles nos universités on
connaît les cycle d'évolution de ces des
parcours de formation entre 4 et 5 ans
donc on peut quand même se poser la
question comment dans une technologie
qui évolue aussi vite et dont
aujourd'hui ça reste quand même le far
west
comment on arrive à faire évoluer au
mieux c'est
ces formations avec ses emplois
aujourd'hui c'est une grande question
des désaccords qu'on interrogeait des
universités et le deuxième point qui
veut vraiment avoir un tête c'est le
manque de doctorants qui ressort est
également le manque de personnes qu'on
peut mettre à disposition des formations
pour faire monter en gamme
nos étudiants pourquoi parce que un
doctorant entre choisir un de donner des
cours dans du public dans une grande
école ou se faire payer par un gars
femme est partie où aller dans le privé
on a vite fait là le calcul voilà donc
on a ce premier point qui est
relativement compliquées entre un far
west
et puis aussi des manques au niveau de
l'enseignement final ça c'est le premier
point mais il ya d'autres métiers
impactant il ya des métiers qui sont
autour de la neurologie
de la résolution de problèmes si on les
oublie à l'intérieur de cette équation
je pense qu'on va faire l'intelligence
artificielle des années 2005 et je pense
qu'on est que là on serait vraiment en
dehors de la situation et ça servi à
rien de former la première cohorte de
nos technologue en intelligence
artificielle et puis le troisième point
sur les impacts en sont des métiers qui
réfléchissent ou business de demain
voilà on sait pourquoi il faut vraiment
avoir ces trois points techno
compréhension de la résolution de
problèmes et également la création de
deux nouveaux business parce que si on
n'a pas les trois ça ne sert à rien de
créer tous nos parcours de formation
pourquoi parce que nos entreprises de
demain mettront la clé sous la porte
ça c'est le premier point c'est ce qu'on
a pu voir au niveau des hauts de france
le deuxième point ce sont les métiers
impactés c'est la grosse partie des
métiers
on a étudié en eau de france 540 de
métiers différents sur 23 secteurs sur
542 il y en a cent quarante trois qui
sont des métiers qui sont affectés par
l'intelligence artificielle soit par
l'intelligence artificielle seul voilà
soit par l'intelligence artificielle
couple est une autre technologie
aujourd'hui on parlait de robolution au
départ il faut vraiment avoir en compte
que l'intelligence artificielle va
modifier entièrement la robotique
l'automatisation et c'est donc on va
avoir une deuxième vague qui va être
beaucoup plus puissante
du fait de l'intégration de
l'intelligence artificielle couplé à
quelque chose d'autre
alors la première vague elle touche
l'intelligence artificielle seules elles
touchent les banques par exemple elle
tant elle touche des métiers qui sont
qui utilisent des logiciels des métiers
qui sont répétitifs mais qui sont peu
manuel demain l'intelligence
artificielle couplé à automates
robotique et autres technologies et
autres plateformes va fonds entièrement
changé notre économie ce qu'il faut
regarder sur ces métiers là qui sont des
métiers spécialisés
ou des métiers répétitif c'est qu'on a
toute la gamme ça va du bac moins quatre
au bac +10 on à la totalité de la gamme
ont parlé toute ardeur des cardiologues
des radiologues
mais il faut parler aussi des infirmiers
des comptables et puis des opérateurs
des techniciens qui sont sur les lignes
de production
donc on a la totalité de l'économie qui
est entièrement touché et ça représente
23 % des emplois qui sont fortement
touchées en eau de france dans les
années futures sur l'intelligence
artificielle mais le problème qui se
pose derrière ça c'est que beaucoup de
ces métiers utilisent peu le numérique
et la digitalisation que ça soit dans la
restauration
que ce soit sur certaines lignes de
production oui parfois il ya des
commandes numériques mais l'interface
est relativement faible avec la machine
demain il va falloir faire monter en
gamme toutes ces personnes-là dont une
partie n'a pas la capacité pour pouvoir
aller sur cette question digitalisation
ça pose une vraie question de nos
parcours de formation mais également de
nos des innovations pédagogiques qu'on
propose pour aider les métiers notamment
dans notre étude des hauts de france
pour pouvoir monter en gamme et
l'innovation pédagogique ne passe pas
obligatoirement par la digitalisation de
la pédagogie
parce qu'on perdrait une partie du
public et notamment de public qui vont
être en est ce qu'ils vont avoir la
technologie de
les technologies d'intelligence
artificielle ou en assistance et donc
vont enfin on va avoir de gros soucis
sur ces questions là donc il ya à
repenser dans cette vague qui est
l'intelligence artificielle nos parcours
de formation et notamment nos
innovations pédagogiques en n'oubliant
pas que tout ne passe pas par le digital
ça c'est ça c'est le point important est
ce qu'il faut on pour finir c'est sur la
problématique de la fidélisation des
salariés si je regarde les chiffres de
la formation dans les dix prochaines
années
il faut à peu près dix mille experts en
eau de france qui vont devoir travailler
sur l'intelligence artificielle
à cela s'ajoute à peu près cent mille
personnes qui vont avoir des maîtrises
d'une partie de l'intelligence
artificielle un logiciel une interaction
bien particulière parce que ils vont
devoir comprendre ce qui se passe dans
cette intelligence artificielle pour
signer en bas de la page pour qu'il
puisse dire ok je suis d'accord avec les
résultats par exemple dans
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le cas
de la banque à la fin il faut que quelqu
un signe le résultat et puis le
troisième point
ce sont des gens qui sont sensibilisés
parce qu'ils sont dans un environnement
ils sont dans le transport ils sont dans
la restauration etc
ils vont devoir travailler avec
l'intelligence artificielle est là juste
sur les hauts de france
on a deux cent cinquante mille personnes
en plus qu'il faut former qu'il faut
sensibiliser
donc on voit on a déjà trois niveaux de
formation pour un expert 10 10 personnes
qui sont sur la maîtrise d'une partie
d'un développement d'intelligence
artificielle et ensuite près de 25
personnes pour un expert qui vont devoir
être sensibilisés rapidement pour on
voit les trois les trois parties ici en
route pour revenir sur ma question de
fidélisation des salariés
aujourd'hui ce qui est le
la grosse problématique des entreprises
c'est le turnover turn over ça
représente à peu près 65 à 67 % des
recrutements qu'on est obligé de faire
dans une société et une partie de ces
turnovers c'est du fait de départs
volontaires vers d'autres cieux d'autres
lieux mais également une perte de
compétences de deux salariés donc si on
regarde ça si on regarde les le
recrutement dans les hauts de france
dans dix prochaines années sur la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
seulement 7 à 8% de ses recrutements
sont des du sang nouveau
le reste entre 93 et 94 % sont des gens
qui sont déjà dans les entreprises donc
ça demande une formation professionnelle
et des moments d'apprentissage bien
particulier pour pouvoir y arriver et ça
ne passe pas obligatoirement un moment
d'apprentissage on ne voyait tout à
l'heure par de la formation et un départ
en formation ça peut se faire sur
d'autres façons tutorat prison compte
d'expérience et ses accompagnements on
peut il ya une multitude de façons de
faire et c'est sur ça qu'il faut
également qu'on travaille sur les
moments d'apprentissage et un moment
d'apprentissage peut être excellent
durant seulement trois minutes et avoir
une vraie efficacité contre parfois
trois 3 jours ou 20 jours de formation
sur lequel il ya de la perte en dit bien
écouter merci beaucoup pour vos
interventions tout très très riche et il
nous reste un petit peu de temps tout de
même pour les questions et le débat donc
je vais
ouvrir à l'ensemble de nos collègues et
puis prendre peut-être une série de
questions qui est ce qui va commencer
alors michel canevet merci beaucoup pour
l'ensemble de ces éclairages sont très
intéressants effectivement on voit avec
des exemples des hauts de france
une identification assez précise des
besoins qui sont tout à fait comme au
chaud alors une première question pour
savoir si la réflexion sur l'ia ne se
cantonne pas à la métropole de lille osc
vraiment l'ensemble de la région hôte
france est à ceux ci est ce que vous
allez c'est mieux de là on est allé dans
le département de l'aisne n'est pas très
content on a vu que là bas il y avait
effectivement un engagement numérique
assez fort a mais tout cela nous
interpelle
peut-être d'autres questions aussi
docteur vous avez eu un discours très
décapants notamment sur l'éducation
comment peut-on faire évoluer notre
système éducatif en france pour répondre
aux enjeux que vous avez évoquées on a
bien entendu qu'il y avait bien sûr la
question des compétences et de la
capacité intellectuelle mais nous avons
aussi l'obligation de former et
d'assurer la réussite de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens donc il faut qu'on
trouve les voies et moyens pour que
chacun trouve sa place dans la société
monsieur andré jacques vous avez évoqué
les métiers de l'internet ce que
aujourd'hui il ya suffisamment de
formation d'établissements de formation
qui sont engagés ce qui à part la
difficulté par le manque d' opéra teurs
et compte tenu de la vitesse à laquelle
les choses vont s qu' on n'a pas pris
beaucoup de retard
madame cathy dit vous avez évoqué
notamment le fait que la formation
résulte est d'abord et avant tout une
question de volonté
or ce chiffre de 15% m'a interpellé
seuls 15% des de nos concitoyens aurait
la volonté véritablement de se former or
il est important que là aussi on a vu
dans les exemples d'autres ans qu'on
aille beaucoup plus loin comment peut-on
faire
comment peut-on faire pour cela monsieur
torossian a été évoqué notamment la
question de la difficulté ou de la
longueur des certifications à ce qu'on
peut avoir un dispositif permettant les
certifications de façon un peu plus
rapide compte tenu de l'évolution des
métiers
et puis on a aussi évoqué donc docteur
vous avez évoqué donc comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la capacité de l'ensemble
des élèves et les difficultés de notre
système éducatif
mais au delà des questions
d'apprentissage donc vous avez dit
qu'elles étaient relativement limitées à
l'école est ce qu'il n'ya pas qu'à mais
aussi par leur réseau scolaire un
certain intérêt dedans par l'émulation
par le regroupement par l'intelligence
collective qui respire résulte du
regroupement de l'ensemble des élèves et
qui par eux mêmes
il va permettre de la progression en
fait
et j'irai d'acquérir un certain nombre
de connaissances est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres questions pourquoi groupe
oui alors sébastien meurant
4 catherine fournier alors sébastien
merci a tous les traits donc très
rapidement pour pour décapant
effectivement sens de 100 mille jeunes
qui sortent toujours sans formation
notre système scolaire ça fait des
années que ça dure
il ya des années que l'on sait qu'il
nous manque des formations techniciens
ingénieurs dans le domaine de
l'informatique
le buzz le marché français a besoin
d'une quarantaine de milles depuis de
d'étudiants formés on n'enferme pas
assez ça fait des années que ça dure
concernant le scolaire si les classes
dédoublées fonctionne pas qu'est-ce qui
est ce qu'il faut faire
concernant l'obligation de ce qu'elle 16
ans concernant des modèles qui
fonctionnent comme la suisse qu'est-ce
que vous recommander à catherine
fournier oui merci madame la présidente
merci à toutes et tous pour cette
présentation
je voulais donc revenir mois déjà avec
monsieur torossian sur l'adaptation de
l'éducation nationale à cette
intelligence artificielle et à ces
nouveaux métiers qu'elles qu'elles
présentent quelque part ou qu'elle
prédispose parce qu'on sait bien que
bien que vous ayez la capacité à
à comment un comment à vous adapter je
pense que l'adaptation qui manque
peut-être à l'éducation nationale c'est
la réactivité c'est pas l'anticipation
en anticipation vous l'avez mais c'est
la réactivité
donc ça c'est mon premier point et je
reviendrai sur le docteur alexandre
aussi sur l'analyse scientifique qui a
été fait par les britanniques
j'aurais aimé pensez peut-être dans
l'erreur que le fait de solliciter le
cerveau humain dans l'apprentissage à
prendre donc au niveau de l'éducation
pouvait le faire évoluer dans le bon
sens et qu'on aurait
le sentiment que finalement c'est là où
l'éducation est au centre et surtout
l'éducation dès le plus jeune âge
eh bien on pouvait faire évoluer ce
cerveau et faire en sorte de pâte
modifie la génétique je suis pas
scientifique mais tout au moins de deux
d'avoir cette évaluation positive de
dire mais on a encore cette chance de
pouvoir penser qu' on va évoluer dans le
bon sens voilà merci merci madame la
présidente j'ai une question mais vous
me permettrez une réflexion juste avant
de poser ma question
ce n'est pas un reproche que je vais je
vais faire mais je remercie d'abord et
ses intervenantes les intervenants mais
je n'ai déjà dit je pense que nous
devrions travailler à une plus grande
diversité de courants de pensée dans nos
intervenantes et intervenants
je pense que c'est dans la contradiction
qu on ressort les meilleurs débat et je
dis ça pourquoi parce que je pense que
le débat que vient de poser monsieur
alexandre il faut qu'on aille au bout
moi je pense que ça peut être
extrêmement dangereux sur une partie de
ce que vous avez dit parce qu'après je
peux revenir soit un certain nombre
c'est que lorsqu'on est un scientifique
qui vient nous dire voilà l'état du
savoir de la génétique
à l'heure actuelle sur un fait que vous
donnez comme si c'était une vérité
absolue qui dit que 73 % des gens qui ne
sont qui ne n'aborde pas bien la
question de la lecture
c'est de fait c'est génétique alors
peut-être que je n'ai pas
jeudi que son chiffre
oui mais mais oui parce que excusez moi
je n'ai pas votre niveau de connaissance
ni même jeu mais vous voulez expliquerez
en bon professeur que vous êtes je n'ai
pas fait de grandes écoles et je sors
d'un milieu très populaire avec deux
parents ouvriers donc vous pourrez me
faire le professeur que vous êtes je
vais vous dit que ce chiffre là est
extrêmement dangereux je connais la
controverse que vous avez avec bourdieu
si nous commençons à dire que oui il est
mort mais vous avez un compte
mais allez-y on ne peut avoir le débat
moi je suis un homme de débat mais on
n'a jamais taire et juraient ils ont
recours au goût de ce que j'ai envie je
dis que lorsque vous dites cela et que
vous assénez comme une vérité est que
cette question là et génétique jeudi
qu'elle peut être dangereux parce
qu'elle nie des questions sociales
symbolique y compris après avoir débat
sur le déterminisme social et culturel
mais lorsque l'on dit ça ça peut laisser
penser à amener le politique les
politiques que nous sommes à dire ben
voila vous voyez moi je suis élu en
seine-saint-denis je sais que nous avons
beaucoup de différence avec mon collègue
euro qui est lui aussi dans le val
d'oise mais nous avons des des
difficultés communes dans notre dans nos
départements respectifs
mais lorsque nous disons cela si nous
avons des difficultés dans le terme
éducatif est évidemment que l'école on
lui demande beaucoup mais nous avons des
difficultés mais si nous pensons qu'une
partie de ses difficultés
elles sont d'ordre génétique et que de
toute façon nous ne pouvons rien y faire
je dis que ça peut amener le politique à
dire mais finalement n'investissons plus
là dedans et on ne peut rien faire pour
changer les choses je dis que ce
discours est extrêmement dangereux par
contre je peux partager avec vous une
question c'est que par exemple sur le
revenu universel
moi je suis fondamentalement opposés à
cette question là pas pour le même avis
vous mais je pense que si nous disons
que nous découpons leurs voeux le
salaire évidemment du capital alors nous
allons abandonner
c'est à dire que nous ne réduirons pas
les inégalités
social les inégalités de salaires ce que
c'est l'impôt qui va payer le salaire et
que c'est le capital va être exonéré
tout voyez on a au final
au final nous ne sommes pas d'accord
pour la même solution la même chose mais
nous pouvons avoir des points d'accord
maintenant j'ai une question
c'est l'ira et la repolitisation y
compris dans la société actuelle par
exemple nous avons un débat mais qui est
pris par beaucoup de gens sur l'ubs et
risation de ce qu'on appelle de la
société l'intelligence artificielle et
vous l'avez dit un certain nombre
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
faible que vous appelez contrairement à
l'intelligence forte et la
conscientisation l'intelligence faible
c'est lui même qui l'a dit riche et
l'algorithme c'est l'humain est donc la
question qui est posée
c est ce que la robotisation à
l'intelligence artificielle va être je
dirai au service de l'humain des
salariés pour moins quand on travaille
par exemple pour partager le temps de
travail pour par exemple nous visitons
des entreprises la robotisation je n'y
suis pas opposé
si elle permet à ce que des métiers
extrêmement difficile le soin - et moi
je pense que le travail se transformera
toujours et nous aurons toujours besoin
de travailleurs ou est ce que
l'intelligence artificielle et la
robotisation va être uniquement tourné
sur la question du profit et l'ong là je
pense que c'est une question extrêmement
politique voilà je vous remercie
voilà je pense que tout le monde a à
tout le monde à poser à peu près ces
questions on va vous laisser bien sûr
docteur répondait chacun votre tour
allez on commence vous pouvez mettre
votre micro souffert l'exprimer puisque
vous m'avez mal compris la grandeur de
l'humanité s'est cassée les déterminisme
génétique et pas de les nier la leucémie
de l'enfant les 100% génétique mais
pourtant occase ce déterminisme
génétique par la chimiothérapie par les
traitements et aujourd'hui l'immense
majorité des enfants leucémiques ne
meurent plus de la leucémie
nous avons cassé un déterminisme
génétique pour l'éducation il faut faire
la même chose constaté qu'il ya des
déterminisme génétique en matière de
capacités intellectuelles et de
réceptivité à l'éducation n'est pas un
constat d'échec bien au contraire
nous devons nous battre dans les 50
années qui viennent pour casser les
déterminismes neuro-génétique les
déterminisme génétique intellectuelle et
c'est ça la grandeur de la politique de
l'école et d'une société humaine
donc nous ne devons pas nier ces
différences sinon nous ne pourrons pas
les combattre pour combattre les
inégalités il faut en comprendre les
ressorts y compris des ressorts qui ne
sont pas politiquement correct mais pas
pour s'en satisfaire et pour maintenir
une société à deux vitesses
mais pour au contraire se bat contre eux
et moi personnellement mon combat en
matière d'intelligence artificielle
n'est pas un combat de classes destinées
à ne rien faire sous prétexte qu'il y à
du déterminisme ma profession médicale a
passé sa vie à casser les déterminisme
génétique en médecine nous essayons de
casser le déterminisme génétique de la
mucoviscidose et l'espérance de vie des
microbicides aux yeux elle est presque
identique aux gens qui n'ont pas de
mucoviscidose alors c'est une maladie
100% génétique
le médecin passe sa vie à casser des
déterminisme génétique médicaux
l'éducateur l'enseignant
le politique doit passer sa vie
maintenant à casser les déterminisme
génétique intellectuelle je voudrais
juste juste un oui de l'arrivée du mot
pendant que vous avez la bahia il ya un
truc dont on n'a juste pas parler qui
est un peu le tabou français sur le
sujet on n'a pas prononcé le mot gafa ni
beatrix on n'a pas dit un mot des gens
qui contrôlent l'ia parce que y'a aucun
producteur d'intelligence artificielle
dans les hauts de france ni nulle part
en france et en europe les seuls
producteurs dialogue dans le monde c'est
google apple facebook amazon microsoft
ibm et baidu et alibaba tencent exil au
mit en chine nous n'avons aucun vrai
producteur dia en tout cas aucun
producteur de 10 plan digues et là on a
un problème pour les hauts de france et
ailleurs
je vous rappelle que récemment google a
passé des accords extrêmement forts sur
l'exploration pétrolière avec total
total a franchi le traitement de son
exploration pétrolière à google renault
nissan a abandonné les voitures
autonomes et a passé un accord avec
google et maintenant les voitures
autonomes de renault nissan et bals
seront made in google la même chose dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique on pourrait
multiplier les exemples
et on a même vu la tentative d'intrusion
de facebook dans la banque et dans la
monnaie avec libre a donc
rapport à l'avenir de la france face à
l'intelligence a deux fils on ne peut
pas ne pas parler des gaffes à dire
l'effondrement technologique de l'europe
en matière d'intelligence artificielle
doit être souligné le rapport villani à
cacher cet effondrement
mais je voudrais juste pour ne voudrais
pas casser l'ambiance mais le budget
nine riaa qui est le fer de lance de
l'intelligence artificielle française
ces 250 millions le budget recherche du
seul amazon c'est 30 milliards à l'inria
c'est le sens et le 130e d'amazones nous
n'auront pas d'intelligence à triel si
nous continuons à ne rien investir en
europe en matière d'intelligence
artificielle et nous serons
effectivement une colonie technologique
une colonie numérique
donc si nous voulons cléo france ne
coule pas il va falloir comme d'autres
régions il va falloir qu'on développe
des compétences de plateforme hisser des
compétences son intelligence afin que
nous n'avons absolument pas et c'est un
énorme problème et on n'a pas réfléchi
et le fait que pendant cette matinée
le mot n'est pas été prononcé montre
bien qu'on confond voit pas bien là bon
on ne saisit pas la difficulté de la
situation
aujourd'hui avec l'apparition de géants
qui sont des vrais des vrais outils géo
stratégiques que sont les géants de
l'intelligence raphia un dernier point
il ya un truc si on veut sauver les
territoires et si on veut éviter leur
dévitalisation a l'air de l'intelligence
et de fiel il va falloir qu'on
maintienne des balances cognitive
équilibré parce qu'au xxième siècle la
balance commerciale est moins importante
que la balance cognitive la balance des
cerveaux quand vous prenez en parler
avec mon voisin je peux vous montrer
aujourd'hui les l'état des hauts de
france en matière de compétences et de
capacités c'est terrifiant c'est là
c'est la zone où les gens sont le moins
bien formés ou ilan moins
moins de compétences techniques et donc
on a une fuite de cerveaux vers les
métropoles qui est terrifiante
les hôtes france sont en train de se
vider de leur cerveau et la france est
en train de se vider de ses cerveaux en
recherche dans un certain nombre de
maîtres domaine je vous rappelle que
dans le figaro n'y a pas très longtemps
antoine petit le patron du cnrs s'est
alarmé du fait que un spécialiste en
intelligence artificielle français dans
la recherche publique à l'inria au cnrs
bac + 11 soit payé moins de 3000 euros
par mois google vous propose 10 100 1000
fois plus donc on a là un énorme
problème qu'il va falloir traiter le
président de la république qui hier a
parlé de deux des risques pour la
recherche google et les autres est
extrêmement bien leur cerveau
si nous ne faisons pas attention là
encore c'est pas politiquement correct
la recherche publique française qui est
indispensable ne va garder que les
troisièmes couteaux avant de poursuivre
je crois que fabien gay voulait réagir
et alors et guillaume arnel on va
essayer d'être si je vais être très
synthétique ou une vérité assénée même
avec une voix très forte ne fait pas une
vérité et je le redis monsieur alexandre
et oui je le redis voilà une vérité
énorme
une affirmation dit même avec une voix
forte n'est pas une vérité excusez moi
la saison déterminisme culturel
peut-être fait fourche et je le redis je
pense que vous arrêter au milieu du gué
et je pense que c'est ça qui fait que ça
peut poser problème est que ce discours
là peut être pris politiquement et nous
mettre face à une situation politique
difficile
vous dites moi je ne dis pas que nous
sommes tous égaux par exemple vous
prenez 25 enfants il y en a qui
apprendront plus rapidement les
mathématiques plus rapidement le
français etc ça certes mais vous vous
dites à un moment ne vous arrêtez à vite
ya un déterminant fin il ya une question
génétique mais vous ne dites pas qu'il
ya aussi des aspects sociaux et
culturels
mais oui mais vous dites pas le
contraire mais vous ne le dites pas donc
ça peut aller c'est à l'interprétation
en plus vous êtes un scientifique et
vous courrez plateaux télévision nos je
dirais que ce schéma la pensée
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que vous
dites vous cassez pas les codes vous
êtes dans un schéma de pensée dominant
ultra dominant et vous le savez est
d'ailleurs pour justement le dire vous
dites on vient casser l'école mais tous
les jours les plateaux de télévision
sont en veille personnes qui ont votre
courant passait et qu'il dise on casse
les codes et je dis que nous sommes face
à une difficulté c'est que si nous ne
disons pas qu'il ya aussi les schémas
culturels et sociaux pour rééquilibrer
les inégalités alors alors
nous sommes face à un problème qui est
extrêmement politique et voix mais comme
vous ne le dit pas et vous laisser à
penser
non ce n'est pas un procès d'intention
autres je vais au bout au bout du débat
politique avec vous peut-être que ces
voix là bon ben vous voyez comme les
choses sont dites bon mais non mais très
bien le sait que ça ça va au bout d'une
controverse mais je pense que c'est
utile que l'on dit et je vous le redis
madame la présidente je pense que quand
on invite monsieur alexandre qui est une
personnalité connue et reconnue
je dis qu'il faut un plateau qui
d'équivalence pour aussi porter la
contradiction
moi je dit aussi qu'on n'est pas dans un
débat idéologique là un nom enfin c'est
parce qu'on a souhaité à nous on
souhaite avoir des témoignages des uns
et des autres donc ça a été le cas mais
c'est très bien qui est du débat juste
guillot marne elle voulait rapidement
s'est rapidement président la barasse et
l'ensemble des intervenants mais plus
particulièrement j'étais enfin beaucoup
plus attentifs et je m'en excuse auprès
des autres mais sur la première
intervention du docteur alexandre et
même si je n'ai pas le la voix de 2 de
fabien moi je me pose quelques questions
je partage avec vous monsieur alexandre
est certain nombre de constats
nous le disons aussi au sénat nous
n'investissons pas assez dans
l'éducation dans la recherche
et c'est donc certain nombre
d'observations qui a été formulée sur la
fuite des cerveaux
lorsque vous avez une sommité comme le
docteur le professeur montagnier que au
sommet de sa gloire
vous lui dites stop à 55 ans vous pouvez
plus exercer y part aux états unis et ça
interpelle donc vous avez en partie
raison dans un certain nombre
d'affirmations cependant moi j'aurais
souhaité savoir quel est l'objectif
recherché de simplement dire les choses
si ce n'est pas repris parce qu'ils ont
les pleins pouvoirs d'influer dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
les choses à vous écouter est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres personnalités ou d'autres
personnes qui partagent votre point de
vue pour qu' il ya une réflexion plus
globale
une extraction de d'une partie de la
substance que vous que vous vous
exprimer pour que justement ça puisse
être traduit dans des réalités et les
convictions politiques
parce que c'est vrai que vous écoutez
sans la contrepartie on se dit mais
finalement c'est tout moi pour confier
au moi je suis un mi-8 je suis un pur
produit du système français
je connais ses imperfections je suis
prêt à trouver avec d'autres des
solutions pour y remédier mais de grâce
je suis l'un des premiers à une pâture
que chez nous tout et tout est noir et
que chez les suisses mal à ce que j'ai
dit moi j'ai insisté sur un point nous
devons investir massivement sur la
recherche en pédagogie pour arriver à la
situation actuelle où 80% des cancers de
l'enfant
son délit et 55 % des cancers de
l'adulte sont guéris ce qui est encore
insuffisant
nous avons investi en recherche des
milliers de milliards de dollars sur
chaque sous-groupe de cancer du sein on
a investi des dizaines de milliards en
recherche pour arriver à sauver un
malade sur deux et quatre enfants sur 5
or nous n'investissons rien sur la
recherche en pédagogie quasiment rien
pour arriver à réduire les inégalités
intellectuelle dont je parlais tout à
l'heure il va falloir investir des
milliers de milliards l'échelle de la
planète
or nous n'investissons rien parce que
les élites sont égoïstes et que ces
inégalités conviennent parfaitement aux
élites politiques aux élites financières
qui finalement ne s'intéressent pas tant
que ça la réduction des inégalités
intellectuelle et donc des inégalités
sociales dans une économie de la
connaissance et donc personnellement mon
combat c'est qu'on investisse autant
dans la recherche en éducation pour
réduire les inégalités intellectuelle
qu'on investit dans la recherche sur le
cancer parce que de mon point de vu
diminuer les inégalités intellectuelle
et donc sociale c'est un sujet au moins
aussi important que de réduire le taux
de mortalité des cancéreux très bien
merci beaucoup alors monsieur torossian
et ensuite à vous tous on a un petit peu
de temps un tout petit peu peut-être
tempérons un petit peu la question de le
la soi-disante inefficacité des mesures
proposées par le ministre bancaire sur
le dédoublement héros moteur et on va
les remettre en perspective d'abord
d'une part nous avons réduit de 8%
les deux
2 8% les les élèves les plus en
difficulté et c'est ça qui nous
intéresse est de 12% les élèves en
mathématiques
donc c'est à dire que certes c'est pas
encore spectaculaire mais laissez le
temps s'il vous plaît aux mesures de
s'installer et on va je veux dire un
petit mot on peut pas avoir des effets
massifs parce que c'est toute une chaîne
c'est ce que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
sur le plan mathématique
moi je la firme aujourd'hui 100% des
élèves peuvent réussir en mathématiques
les mathématiques avec si on essayait la
mise en oeuvre des vingt-et-une mesure
d'en proposer avec seyrig mélanie c'est
à dire que effectivement et je rejoins
le docteur alexandre ce point il s'agit
pas uniquement de pédagogie mais ceux-ci
de didactique de d'une réflexion c'est
un sujet sur lequel il ya eu quand même
et en menant de recherche depuis 50 ans
la pédagogie beaucoup de pédagogie
autour du socioconstructivisme un qui
nous a peut-être mis dans une direction
sur lequel il faudrait peut-être revenir
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
dans notre rapport est je pense le sait
sans doute une bonne question donc c'est
à dire que effectivement l'efficacité de
l'enseignement doit être réinterrogé
c'est ce que nous faisons dans ce
rapport des méthodes plus explicite et
on a cru que effectivement les élèves
allaient construire leur savoir
malheureusement il faut bien constater
que notamment avec les classes
populaires et nous en sommes nous sommes
nombreux de sorte à table en sortir et
bien effectivement l'enseignement
explicite est beaucoup plus efficace
ça on le sait depuis 30 ans des études
américaines
donc les choses sont claires la
direction dans laquelle il faut prendre
donc ça on la met en oeuvre aujourd'hui
sur les mathématiques on le met en
oeuvre sur l'apprentissage de la lecture
le retour effectivement un enseignement
plus efficace sur la lecture fait que
aujourd'hui dans nos classes dédoublées
et dans l'est dans l'ensemble des
classes en france les élèves qui sont en
décembre là aujourd'hui on est dans un
mois seront lire on a des efforts on a
des progrès on a eu des progrès là
constaté effectivement radicaux en
changeant effectivement certaines
méthodes
pédagogique et le ministre le ministre
le souligner à de nombreuses reprises
donc oui les mesures cpd doublé ont un
effet faible peut-être au regard de
l'ensemble mais intéressant et constater
aujourd'hui sur les élèves qui en ont
plus besoin c'est à dire les élèves en
difficulté et moi ça me rassure notre
part ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui sur
sur l'enseignement aux primaires
montrent que sur la résolution de
problèmes en mathématiques
nous sommes les derniers de la classe
bien nous nous le disons aujourd'hui
nous pouvons remonter dans le peloton en
mettant en place effectivement sur toute
la chaîne et c'est ce que nous faisons
avec jean michel blanquer aujourd'hui
sur avec un plan de formation massif
donc on a pris les affaires très au
sérieux autour de la formation des
adultes
nous avons trois cent cinquante mille
professeurs des écoles à former nous
avons un plan en quatre ans c'est à dire
qu'on se place dans ce chemin
stratégique sur plusieurs années donc ça
c'est le premier point sur la question
va sembler qu'il était important que je
puisse réagir sur les attaques
on a des attaques sur la réactivité du
système éducatif face aux changements
donc effectivement il ya des invariants
éducatif
la question de savoir est ce que
l'éducation nationale doit s'adapter aux
technologies ou le contraire c'est une
question qu'on essaye de traiter depuis
30 ans force est de constater que
effectivement la question c'est plutôt
l'appétence il faut donner le goût
plutôt aux enfants de pouvoir apprendre
à se diriger et donc effectivement nous
avons une certaine difficulté sur
l'intelligence artificielle et autour de
l'informatique
c'est un véritable enjeu pour nous on a
mis en place pour lapointe ffa et nous
sommes le seul pays dans le monde à
avoir mis en place un enseignement
massif d'informatique
alors peut-être que certains pays sont
plus avancées mais quand même on peut le
dire jean michel blanquer a mis en place
l'enseignement informatique en classe de
première c'est une première mondiale
c'est un début laissez nous le temps de
construire toute cette chaîne
donc effectivement et de monter en
monter peut-être 20 ou 30% de la
population dans cette direction voilà
la pression que cela donne c'est que on
ne va pas assez vite
enfin moi je dis mon impression
personnelle parce que le monde ne bouge
très très vite et bien sûr qu'on met des
mesures en place bien sûr qu'il ya
beaucoup de bonnes volontés etc
mais est ce que est ce que on est assez
rapide
et est-ce que j'en profite pour vous
poser la question est ce que au niveau
de l'éducation nationale vous ne trouvez
pas que le lien avec l'entreprise est
suffisamment inexistant et qu' il
faudrait pas mettre en place des mesures
on l'a dit souvent pragmatique des
stages préparatoires en entreprise est
ce que ça ne devrait pas faire partie du
cursus de formation des enseignants ont
levé les célèbres mm elle est passée
mais on le fait d'un premier je vais un
peu qualifiés donc on a parlé de volonté
de se former j'allais un peu dit dans
quand j'ai abordé la question la
première fois alors déjà le chiffre se
réfère aux gens qui disent que ils n'ont
pas reçu en f1 qui n'ont pas qu'il n'y
avait pas dans les 12 mois précédant une
formation qu'ils auraient voulu le
suivre mais n'ont pas suivi donc ça veut
dire que il aura pu ne pas recevoir
d'offre qui sont appropriés pour donc il
ya cet élément qui est bien au delà de
la motivation et après je dirais aussi
que même parmi ceux qui disent non non
non pas forcément une forte motivation
et pour être démotivés c'est à dire que
ils voient les barrières la
participation comme tellement notre le
coup les difficultés financières qu'ils
considèrent pas qui est que c'est
possible pour et donc effectivement il
ils répondent qu'il n'y avait rien
qu'ils auraient pu faire donc c'est un
mélange de choses cela dit il ya
effectivement tout un travail je pense
que je met ensemble ces éléments parce
que la réponse est quand même d'essayer
de lui faire comprendre qu'il ya des
chemins qu'il y à des formations qui
peuvent marcher pour qu'il ya des
financements auxquels ils peuvent
accéder et que la formation est
importante pour eux pour les accompagner
dans les transitions oqali devant faire
face tout probablement dans le futur
après je voulais dire de dans tout ce
débat encore à prennent un peu de recul
avec des comparaisons un peu
internationale je dirais que des modèles
qui manche quand même existe mais on a
tendance